[Music]
hey guys we're now exactly two weeks
from the first episode of the final
season and in that light nunca me
transfer edge for season eight has been
released as you may have realized a
bunch of this footage we have already
seen there's some new interesting stuff
in there starting material speech you
matter fellas Great Hall theorem says we
must fight together now or die
while in the background they can also
notice that in sensor Danny engineer
Cruz said aramis will arrive a man fell
in the very beginning of season eight
and as it was expected the northerners
will not accept her as good as John did
it has been officially confirmed for
quite a long time ago that sense and
Danny will have a very tense first
meeting and it was also recently
confirmed that Tyra Norton Lord so
Savage Sansa and shared the same
feelings towards the dragon queen the
northerners will need some convincing to
trust them according to Bella Ramsay her
character Lyanna Mormont is not very
happy with the arrival of a foreign
Queen so it's not only sense the who
gives some hard time to John or Danny
but it's also the northern lords and
ladies as well and this right here is
the first meeting summoned by Jon Snow
upon their arrival at the novel since
the northerners did not accept any very
well Tyrion is pretty much saying they
might not like each other but they must
fight together nonetheless or otherwise
they will all die this page should bring
the northerners to their senses and they
will sooner or later realized the
Danny's armies and Dragons are the only
hope in this great war although the
Targaryen might not be the only reason
owners are upset about it could also be
that northerners don't like the ideal
fighting alongside his brother Jaime
Lannister hos arrival at Winterfell was
first letís with official season 8
photos and then confirmed by the trailer
northerners are not happy about
Targaryen Salinas sursum NFL and that's
why Tyrion says they must fight together
now or die next - have they any standing
in front of a fireplace but her back
turned to John the first thing I
realized from this clip is that this is
obviously an intense meeting between
John and Danny at second note I noticed
her battle hair the full single braid
looking into details I figured this must
be from episode 4 because they're not
the mirror fell here
there are a Dragonstone take a look at
the props fireplace the stone curves and
the metalwork it's the same thing we
already saw a gemstone so now we know
they will retreat the gemstone after we
NFL Falls looks like John and Danny will
have a tense conversation that they're
losing the battle for NFL and since
their Dragonstone this clip is likely
from episode four and it's a post-fight
moment but also seemingly post just your
parentage revealed moment as well
throughout these past seven seasons we
all know that John would eventually
learn his true lineage at first we hoped
he'd find out who was his mother and
then after huge twists we hoped he'd
soon find out about both his mother and
his true father he did not learn the
truth yet but since this is the final
season we know he will find it out now
Kit Harington teased this about his
character just know the end of the world
might be coming soon but at least he's
in love with somebody and knows who is
and then comes a sledgehammer his
parentage revealed will be a huge blow
to John and his relation should be Danny
and it's not surprising a sledgehammer
to John will likely come from brain or
even more likely from saying then it
does seem to be upset and John simply
doesn't know how to deal with all of
this the night king being close and him
being a Targaryen at the same time how I
picture this scene is it's after they've
learned about John Hsu parentage but
also after they've learned that Dana is
pregnant so they don't know how to feel
about all that just yet but still they
have to make plans I also like how at
this point we all speak about Dana's
pregnancy as effect without any footage
or dialogue confirming it but after all
the season 7 Clues hints and for
sheriff's I don't think we even need to
wait for it it might have even been
officially confirmed by the showrunners
there's one in a real image game
internal showrunners david at dane are
discussing Danny's potential pregnancy
with Kit Harington an actor that
portrays Jon Snow
it stays Danny says that she cannot have
children and they're like we'll see
about that
on which one of the showrunner slapped
regardless of the scenery of the show's
next big plays their child was heavily
foreshadowed throughout the previous
season multiple times the Danny's
pregnancy became a certain thing the
most prominent one would definitely be
John statement on there is belief that
she cannot have children Danny said I
cannot have children when with John
replied with who told you that
the veg who killed my husband answered a
knee referring to Mira mazdoor
in case you don't remember the prophecy
took place in the season 1 finale and
the witch said this to Danny when the
Sun rises in the West and sets in the
east when the Seas go dry and the
mountains blow in the wind like leaves
when you roam quickest again and you
bear living child then he will return
and not before Jen replied to Danny wait
has it occurred to you she might not
have been a reliable source of
information despite Danis believed that
she cannot have children because of this
prophecy Danny will most definitely be
pregnant with John's baby next time is
here the show's next big twist was also
heavily for share of the Tyrians
conversation with Danny about her plan
for succession as well as the John's
conversation with Jorah immature I did
not want to take long hope but rather
said made survival and your children
after you all these clothes and
foreshadows made us convinced about
Dana's pregnancy and make no mistake
she's definitely pregnant the new
footage also included beric Dondarrion
in the Hound in the midst of the battle
for veneer fell against white walkers
barrack is ready but the Hound is
terrified and in fear of all the fire
rounding we have already seen him in the
state in season 7 when Thoris and
barrack ignited their swords to fend off
the undead Beast then the Hound froze
and it resulted with the bear fatally
burning forests as well as almost
killing the Hound before others killed
it now during this battle it's ten times
worse then it was only two flaming
swords that made the Hound freeze and
now it's basically the Battle of the
Blackwater 2.04 the Hound
better fel is on fire there flaming
swords around and probably flaming
arrows flying everywhere around however
also think this is going to be a moment
the kondal final defeat his fear of fire
and actually be of some help for the
Starks then we have Danny again this
time in the courtyard of Winterfell this
clip is from the season 8 premiere it's
from eating all the Starks then is in
the ground level of NFL quarter then
looking down and she's a little upset
likely listening to brain in his
wheelchair he's telling her about the
wall denying him his area brain
basically shares the news that the night
king is the dragon to bring down the
wall and it will not take long until
they're here as we all know Danny knew
she loved the dragon but she did not
know the night king reanimated him and
will basically fight any in the future
so this is definitely coming as a huge
shock to the
Queen from this promotion for oversee
the few days ago we know for a fact that
brain will be welcoming John Snow
maintaining the courtier just like
everyone else
next we have the unsullied raising their
shields which journalist edges as we all
know journalist also known as obsidian
is the key to killing the nine kings and
as along with Valyrian steel it's one of
the two known substances capable of
killing both the White Walkers and the
whites the living will use journalists
in every way possible
and your footage also provided this clip
of joining Arya being in the godswood of
Winterfell this could very well be the
reunion and one can only say finally Ari
and John have not seen each other since
season 1 when they hear clothes sibling
relationship and they just missed the
chatter in season 7 and now in season 8
they will finally reunite I don't think
I will be with sense and brain in the
courtyard of Winterfell and John and
Danny arrive she seems to be a minute
town at the moment of Jenkins arrival
and also I would like more if John Inari
arena at a bit later without anyone else
around him it's going to be
heartbreaking
we also see a new glimpse of just no
fighting during the battle for Rena fell
and lighting some candles in the crypts
of NFL but nothing else we could get out
of it
finally we have Ares that was the
interior nave NFL standing right next to
journalist surprisingly shockingly
looking up a dragon or jeggings these
three have already seen dragons about
their heads quite a lot of times so the
only reason they would look up with a
bit of shock would be number one it's
not just any dragon it's the eyes dragon
the knife king dragon or more likely to
is just on writing Dana's either dragon
Rago since the night king will arrive at
Winterfell in episode 3 and since it
will actually be at night we can say for
a fact that least we are not looking at
the 19th dragon but they could be
looking at Jon Snow writing ragle a
dragon named after John's father Rhaegar
Targaryen in the trailer we see John and
Danny approaching drawn in Rago we know
Danny is obviously heading to write
dragon and seemingly John is getting to
write the other one as well before we
end this video there's one more thing
that I'd like to discuss and at this
promotional season 8 folder we see
Tyrion and Ben are fairly boxes full of
journalists next to him and the dragon
glass is actually being added to
Schuette frieze which is a defensive
antic cavalry measure Jon meant to
Dragonstone not only to me the dragon
queen but also to mine journalist that
located over there with John and Dana's
arrival of NFL of course the broad
journalists from general stone it was it
in the war to come and therefore their
army scaring the journalists made
weapons doesn't come as a surprise as I
already said the journalist is the key
to defeating the White Walkers so the
living has to use it in every way
possible as we learned from the trailers
some part the army of the living will
fight anything outside Winterfell and so
they need some protection around them
the unsullied form a phalanx formation
their famous battle tactic a large group
of them fighting in lockstep failing
says using spear and shield which in
this case has jus on it as well with
this formation then once defeat in an
army that was approximately seven times
bigger in numbers now solid will take a
defensive position behind the lines of
shioda freeze with journalists sticking
out of the spikes as already said this
defense is often used against cavalry
but the knight King doesn't have any so
this is a little bit confusing White's
can only remember how to use a sword but
I cannot use vows and arrows Sarada
complex tools including riding horses
I guess mindless White's could be just
running straight into it nevertheless
this is an eighth photo is very
interesting in conclusion this new
footage did reveal a lot but most
importantly we now know for a fact there
Dana in John Snow and the living in
general will retreat after losing the
battle for vana fell they will go to
gemstone and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace